i took a picture of you and pearl and in
the corner
there's the there's a face and i've
zoomed in it's your high school your
third grade girl
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening
paul
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez george lopez oh my god omg
omg
if you're feeling overwhelmed lately
you're not alone start feeling better
with a single message talk space online
therapy matches you with a licensed
therapist
from the comfort of your device that's
very true this is a great talk space is
awesome so we'll give you a hundred
dollars off your first month you can't
just be fixed in one week this is going
to take some time but they're they're
they're ready to give you a hundred
dollars off your first month with the
code omg
at talkspace.com
why cry alone
cry to somebody on the phone
[Music]
the ravens had it
no the raiders had it
when they thought they thought he made a
touchdown he didn't
[ __ ] yeah it went into it was like it
was a kick at the very end of regulation
right to tie it up
it was that was nuts that was not you
were there and then the guy
did they score and they had to score a
touchdown to win yeah
yeah could have done it with the field
goal and they went for the touchdown
instead and they got it the guy was all
alone too wide open and wide open yeah
you could see that receiver just or the
defensive back just give up
he knew he had that that guy ran off the
field that [ __ ] was crazy yeah they were
going crazy
all the pictures that were posted
i uh i put a remark in their
comment and all i said was
is there anybody you don't know
i think i think i know everybody yeah
and then the players
oh yeah well we'll talk about that oh no
we're we're rolling here oh yeah
so
i mean you know when i when the raiders
were in oakland
and
you know growing up in la
ram
ram fan
never went to any game never went to any
ram game at the thrifty
at the thrifties in san fernando but i
think around the stores in kmart so they
sold uh
almost looks like a waste paper basket
like it's this big round
and had pictures of
like a football team on the outside
and had a specific team and if you went
in pittsburgh they probably sold
steelers stuff
and in la you would you would get one of
those and you open it it had a helmet
ram helmet
it had pads
it had a jersey
and a little football in that thing so
you could be like a little fool running
around a [ __ ] concrete
cracking your [ __ ] head open
almost getting hit by a car with a ram
uniform and back then you couldn't
really get a uniform anywhere oh yeah so
i have one of those and
my grandfather you know my grandfather
could give a [ __ ] about their house and
yeah anybody i thought he was a dodger
gamer like kill him [ __ ] with there
the games are shot up
and then uh
when the rams left
because the coliseum was pretty bad now
now that you see where they were playing
wow just like playing on that
that's that new stadium is nuts what is
it what's it allegiant stadium
allegiance yeah yeah they call that the
death star
the death star
uh it ain't as nuts as [ __ ] mark
davis's house
you see that thing
it looks it was those pictures were
posted were bad
you know what was the first one was
gruden you with gruden yeah yeah the the
the the um
if you see mark man
he's you know probably al had a uniform
he's got the white white shirt white
thing
and he has a miniature stadium as his
house
in vegas that's cool it's a variation of
of the stadium so honest it's so on that
guy
yeah
like that's like if you went to my house
and you don't have [ __ ] horses and a
[ __ ] that place entire horse outside
you know water
whatever the [ __ ] apples whatever the
[ __ ] they eat
and you'll be like this is where you
live yep
i don't know you're a cowboy yeah you
know keep that side private
and and
when they came to l.a you go get i mean
you you know you're working then you go
get raiders [ __ ] at the gas station
chair anywhere you get a liquid any
corner that's why i thought that they
took off because you could go to the you
could go get a 12 pack of beer
and a pint of sea grams and then look up
and go hey let me have that raider hat
right there
so you just became a fan just by
going to the liquor store yeah i just
had an extra you know or you put you
know they said do remember these do that
you fill up your if you fill up your
tank you got a raider glass or even if
you if you
bought detergent that would put a glass
in the [ __ ] detergent yeah the
cleanest glass in the world comes out of
the georgia
so
coliseum still probably still the same i
think they added a press box but
it's big and
i mean i went in there
old and [ __ ] seats are all
uncomfortable i went in there when the
jets played the raiders marc gassino was
playing
102 thousand people they lose
they played like [ __ ] they were at home
they played like [ __ ] they they were out
then you go to the coliseum oakland and
i you know i started to go in the last
four or five years because you know it
wasn't the show was on and traveling on
sunday just trying to get home
and that place
was a multi-purpose stadium built as a
multi-purpose stadium and i played golf
with
the guy this guy that used to play for
the
ace and he goes uh i said hey how's that
skating he goes oh because let me give
you an idea how i stayed in the way we
all had to take showers with flip-flops
on
oh
because
sometimes you'd be taking a shower and
[ __ ] would come up from the from the
pipes in the shower oh my god
so imagine all these dudes running out
with their flip-flops on slipping on the
water
knocking them you know and falling down
it was nasty
i'd go home sweaty
yeah yeah right yeah he said man this is
not it's not the [ __ ] place
to play you know they would move [ __ ] in
and then they put the they put the tarp
over those things and it's and you see
this stadium
it was always tough to leave oakland
they left and they come back but
that stadium is
[ __ ] amazing man so i got the new one
for the rams over here not too
yeah
yeah did you get rid of that one yet no
uh no i haven't been down
i can't believe how many fans from here
are going to vegas to watch raiders home
somebody said to me yesterday have you
been to a raider game
i said you know i don't go to gay bars
oh man they said uh i don't know you're
a greater fan i said i'm so much of a
fan
my hair is silver and black man
but when the when the rams left
of course you know my dad left i never
met him so when the rams left i was like
[ __ ] that man you know and then they
come then there was how about there's no
football in la for 25 years nobody gave
a [ __ ]
nobody said
that's when the old that's when the
elote took off too in the park
i think the no football on sunday put
more mexicans in the park the corn came
out of that
you know
tell you a funny story about the rams
leaving when they left l.a they had
you're not going to believe this but
they had they had a dinner at steven's
steakhouse
some guy's leaving there
one of one of my old friends
from patrol there in east l.a pulled
over a car
one of the rand players chuck knox i
believe was the uh coaching he was a
head coach
so he pulls up behind him
and this guy automatically had they had
a regular car that was working dui drunk
drivers that's all he was doing
and so
my buddy pulled this guy over chuck knox
pulls over
and he says sir you know is there
anything we can do you know we can take
riders or promise well he's just a
little bit too much to drink but if you
you take care of him he says that'll in
the problem right now
he says so just put him in your car park
this one and go
and he come back he says sir i'd like
your name he says i want to thank you
very much says
i want to give you some season tickets
for next year he says no no i can't
accept anything i don't want anything
thank you very much that's it you know
you can just go and take him home you
know
everything's good
he says
what's your name
you're going to hear from me he says i'm
going to get you tickets
and they left that was the end of it the
next day was in the paper
announcing
rams leaving los angeles
you pop the trunk you want a cheerleader
pop the truck to come out with the thing
and it would have made any difference
the guy that stopped him was the nicest
guy in the world yeah and it wouldn't
have made a difference he didn't want
anything but still they pulled him on
today we're going to take care and then
that was their going away dinner
they all the players and all the coaches
were there yeah
they were there and they were just the
next day it's announced
rams are moving that's
brutal and then when they came how about
all the 25 years of no football in l.a
and then all of a sudden there's two
teams in la and one from san diego like
the chargers got to find
they got to find a place to
i'm not a charger fan but you got to
find a place to live it's like it's like
somebody's staying at your house
wink wink
that
you got the owner the rams are the
owners of the stadium
and the chargers are just staying there
until they get there
what am i what am i what do my cousins
say one time
you know he went over there when i was
out of town and
my grandmother was alive he fixed the
fat he fixed the faucet you know these
[ __ ] always do come over how
about you some panda say grandma you did
can i stay here yeah
come on [ __ ] guy
[ __ ] five dui [ __ ]
and i come home and he's in the house
and i said go grandma's what's bobby
doing here oh he's gonna stay here
stay here while he fix the sink he's
going to stay here
i said
let's see how this goes because he's not
drinking anymore
uh
that [ __ ] you wake up in the
morning he'd be without his shirt on
with his feet up on the couch and boxers
stuff like a grandmother there man yeah
besides like hey how long are you gonna
be trying to get my feet on the ground
yeah how about [ __ ] taking him off
the couch
and putting some [ __ ] socks on and
some clothes maybe that'll help you go
out there and find a job
and he wasn't supposed to be drinking so
you know he was good for like i forgot
how long he was there like a month
and then on a sunday
car comes around the cul-de-sac
he gets out he's a little bit like this
he gets in there blocks the room with
you know and the next day i said hey man
you drink a little bit last night
yesterday yeah i said you know i think
it's time that
i got him to find another place to live
he goes is that right i said that's
right
you gotta find it because i don't want
her
to see you like that
you did a good thing
been here too long and now you're
starting to drink get the [ __ ] out
i think i'd be a good apartment manager
wouldn't it yeah
you're not getting your [ __ ] deposit
back get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] the
[ __ ] rock through your [ __ ] eye
gonna have that talk with the chargers
uh yeah i'm gonna be talking to the
chargers soon they i think they need to
go they can't go to vegas um
hey maybe they should go to [ __ ]
oakland
the same uniform you don't even have to
hold it away just wear your whatever you
wear to the [ __ ] game
just put your helmets on you don't need
to wear a uniform just bring some
flippers let the [ __ ] running around
oh you won't even have a tv contract we
can just put it on instagram
[Laughter]
but but you know they're not the
so that they you know they're like
renting sure so the
rams built that thing on a fault
to the fault line
and
they put
over a billion dollars in the ground
so that there was an earthquake it would
move around so it's built on like
bands or some [ __ ] it's not built solid
in the ground it's built so if there's
an earthquake it'll move around no
nothing's going to break straps
that's crazy so all adjusters like this
on rollers
yeah oh really yeah yeah so so they're
they're
over budget by three million by three
billion dollars damn
so how is it how is a team supposed to
get out of the hole
three billion dollars call them with
charges see if they want to come down on
that charter
hey
hey bring some
bring the rams some lunch eh
maybe they'll take some off the tab
so they they
but then when they when they went to the
super bowl they didn't win the super
bowl did they they lost
no they didn't who did they play
steven stayhawks
they played the employees of stephen's
steakhouse
right there on the five they closed the
five freeway
kansas city kicked their ass didn't they
was that mahone's first super bowl yeah
you know i'm not a i'm more of a golfer
i don't really watch golf anymore but
i saw my homes playing
and
first of all when you see those dudes
they're [ __ ] huge man like even him
the quarterback he was walking we're
like is that him
so so that game i said let's see if he's
as good as they say man that dude is
like takes two steps back fit they're
like 60 yards but just like that and
you're like man that dude is out of his
mind it's unreal
watching him play the throw in the super
bowl where he was like he was diving he
was like horizontal and he still threw a
perfect pass and the receiver dropped it
like if he had caught that that would
have been one of the most insane
super bowl completions of all time so
it's tough man like when the rams went
to the super bowl the profile was high
then they didn't win but they still went
to the super bowl and instead of going
like this they've gone kind of like that
merchandise and all that stuff so and
they didn't play very well either in the
super bowl that helps i mean if you play
well and you lose
like the rams in tennessee uh titans
that time the last play was the guy
they got him down on the one-yard line
and that was just a great game right
that was a great game yeah
and
it helped both teams but this way if you
play bad now because all the attention
everybody's getting you go
like that
you know and you know rams
i think what's the helmet look like a
better guy like the ram
they're like a dick with a face
you know that there's a guy in porno
that put like flames around his body but
left the handles
goes out with all the hair bellows with
the flames but that but the ram
the ram
helmet when it came out they said do you
think this is a good look and then they
isolated the thing like a like a like a
[ __ ]
you see it i'm never going to look at
that the same way
and yeah yeah look at all those
you can see here's a part that looks
like a dick let me see
just the whole like the little swoopy
i don't know
yeah it's like when you give me that
test to see if you're a [ __ ] local
and you're a big person i don't even
know that this was the new logo oh right
there come on yeah oh right there
come on man
nobody could check that
and then they're using the
[ __ ] logo for channel 2 news as the
la
yeah come on you guys take a look at
your [ __ ] together
and all those guys are over there you
know cedric and anthony and
with steve garvey and eric dickerson and
you know willy galtz
dave winfield you know looking
carrot top and all the dudes
you go you go to the
raider game you're there with [ __ ]
tommy smith with the black glove 1968
olympics yeah [ __ ] dudes that already
been in prison and got out [ __ ]
cholos
with a high voice your [ __ ] george
i love you dark [ __ ] shoulders
[Laughter]
and and to know
it's bad they left
you you would not
you know people married for money and
you go wow this is a lot different than
where you were
even under the stadium [ __ ] marshawn
lynch when we played in oakland we were
hanging out outside he left he took the
bart home he took that [ __ ]
he took the the train back to his house
you know [ __ ] mark you get out there
you got a bottle of hennessy gets on the
bart takes off they're like that's
yeah absolutely they're they're
the underground
when they come out of the locker room
they come down a little ramp
all the
the ravens come out from the other side
the raiders come down the ramp
gruden all hang on parking space
underground all the players come out
through there that's just about as
the most exciting place after a win you
know first game that there's ever been
that's why i saw all the guys players
came out took pictures but they'd stop
and see me and they'd go oh [ __ ] y'all
get much growing up
so great and
you know mark davis out there happy man
happy
i had some guy today saying oh [ __ ]
i had uh spectrum come on my wi-fi has
been down for a few days they come out
to work on it
and they tell you you got to show your
id when they get there to make sure you
know it's legit
so i pull out my
my id says i don't need you don't need
to show me right i know you are
he says i've seen you on the jordan
lopez podcast he says your guild
he says and i saw the documentary and
while he's doing the work around he's
laughing i said what's so funny he says
i'm listening to you i'm listening to
you laugh right now i'm listening to the
podcast while i work so
everybody knows george i bet you when
you [ __ ] go back your computer's gone
while you're laughing
[ __ ] headphones guys stealing you
blind probably took your reading glasses
i don't know why they're still reading
glasses yeah he checked your id but did
you check his hit i got a headache with
his [ __ ] gobbler take him back to
gil's house but yeah those guys yeah
it's cool and all those guys you know
you can get
some type of uh you know a lot of the
[ __ ] other channels for free
but i think that's gonna be i think
that's gonna be
in oakland
it's good that they won but you know in
just in one game all the
revenue 65 000 people hotels
you know the shows and all that stuff
it's gonna be pretty pretty good well
it's going to be a big it it's going to
be they're going to be bigger there than
they were
in la and because there's a bigger draw
because it's vegas
and yeah
i did the groundbreaking i don't know
that's how old i am i thought the state
was going to be open and i said oh it
has a real fun oh that's right
you think how can you play in there
it'll be 120 degrees on a sunday
afternoon so
yeah you go in there
that's how you know
it's probably
70 degrees in there
like when old people walk in the mall
because they're old and
they can't walk in the heat
you go to even if you don't like
football
just buy a ticket and get the [ __ ] out
of the heat
for
five hours yeah
it's it's beautiful never seen this it's
at the top of the fourth beginning of
the fourth quarter the lights go down
and then the ring around the thing goes
raiders
and then everybody in there
their wrists lit up because i guess if
you went and bought a ticket you got a
band to get you in
and
at the beginning of the fourth quarter
they activated that band and everybody
in there it was flashing
oh that's sick i said i've seen the
ankle [ __ ] you've seen the ankle flash
but never the [ __ ] shoulder probably
i got my right hair
but it it's it's going to be
it's going to be wild now the mgm not
the owner of the
of the raiders
you know mgm properties
as in the mgm suite they got 118 seats
in the suite
they came in a single suite and once
they
the guy goes we can't call it a sweep we
gotta call it like a villa complex
118 seats that's crazy with a bar so i
the games over here and i was watching
it over here
that dude jim gray was the other
reporter and again so the guy this other
guy comes up and he goes
you prefer to watch it right here than
there and i said yeah because there
you're watching the whole field and here
you're watching the quarterback
the thing yeah replay the action and
then toward the end i went over there
but it's it's exciting man
it's exciting
oh yeah was that yesterday throwing up
an image
do you have one from the groundbreaking
uh looks just like that god that thing
is insane
yeah i was looking up the stats this guy
was a capacity and they had they had an
anti-vaccination protest out there on
the corner seven people
the [ __ ] about that
yeah so they were you know but it's it's
fun
it's fun i don't know matt the the
vaccination thing is is it's wow because
i don't
you know they're like the good our uh
our government michoa or whatever but
they're not doing it to
listen they were standing on the corner
so they can obey
mandates you can't if they didn't they
[ __ ] stand on the street they climb
on cars they don't do that because
against the law there's rules
and you see little kids holding signs
which is fine but
i think when you
go to
a football game and there's 65 000
people that are screaming for the rams
i'm surprised the rams didn't break up
their protest i mean they're the race
for the raiders that the raiders didn't
break up the protesters they didn't even
approach it like a get-together
[Laughter]
when your protesters come all in the
same car after you've got to regroup
yeah go back out there i'm just
surprised i'm glad there wasn't any any
violence or anything because you know
you think of that [ __ ] being out there
but it's it'll be fun
we'll have to go out there one huh want
to get stephen steakhouse playing him
gluten-free in there the chairs yeah
anything anything you want in that place
if it's if it's sold out he'll hang you
from the right what kind of what kind of
what what's the equivalent of that like
uh uh morton's or no it's not that i
morton's not
sizzler no oh no no
it's it's just a nice steakhouse but
it's not a houston it's not a
ah no i'm not used to dji friday
i don't know what that that one i've
never heard of oh classic uh chain
grew up in the midwest there were a lot
of tgi fridays um
yeah yeah yeah
that's those are chains no not not a
chain restaurant this is a nice
restaurant i can get a nice uh i i like
to go in there and order the big gem
prime rib because i won't eat half of it
just but the next day the morning cut it
up it tastes like a vest i put in the
pan with wubbles oh a little steak and
it's good yeah yeah it's the bomb that's
what you have in the morning for the
first thing in the morning for breakfast
if i had if i've been to stephen yeah
they got a good porterhouse
good fillet
he just had uh during the pandemic he
sent that had some
a pizza oven sent from sicily and they
came and installed it and he's making
some small pizzas something different
because the family's all for me you sure
didn't fall off the [ __ ] truck on the
way to sicily
all right ideally couldn't refuse
hey
i'm just going to say you know watch out
because you're going to have your heart
done they're probably going to do a scan
of your heart and if you look close to
your heart you're going to see usda
[ __ ] step on your heart
all right
[ __ ] so much meat we're doing that
tomorrow
oh good man good luck yeah good luck
good luck i think i think that
yeah i think that
immediately you'll see
the help of that huh i hope so have you
have you ever been afraid to go to the
doctor or anything no no
because you know
have you have you had any issues broken
bones uh broken i broke one bone in
college it's you know
always afraid of like horrible medical
debt but no actual like fear of like
going to see someone about something
when did it become an issue that people
didn't have insurance like if you worked
if when you used to work during the day
wherever
you're probably not here though the uh
after a certain amount like maybe 60
days or whatever you would have medical
and dental yeah and uh um
i you know
and then they took that [ __ ] away and
then somehow
it got to be where you had to pay for
your own insurance
and if you don't have it
i got a lifetime
yeah and if you don't have it they can't
help you right they're [ __ ] they
can't
yes
or they'll help you and you'll be in
debt for
10 years 20 years the rest of your life
they have that uh california care which
is a derivative of the obamacare they
came out people could buy
[Music]
but i've never been afraid of doctors or
anything it turned it into a game you
know they put you to sleep it's always
okay let me know when you're going to
inject because i want to see how far i
can count
oh yeah before i go out
i've already gotten to three
i you know what you know i might have
been a drug addict in another life
i tell the dude
hey
give me half
let me float around
for a couple of minutes because it's
beautiful
so it gives me a half and you're
floating around it's like it's like when
you pee in the bed at first it's warm
and they get cold
you're
and then it gets cold you're like
[ __ ]
you're half and you're floating around
and then he's like okay enough that's
that's all right you sure
backwards
and that's what michael jackson was
trying to use to sleep
and the good thing about that stuff is
it puts you out but when you wake up you
don't remember anything
you
you're gone
you don't remember anything what they
just did to you i think
hopefully
you had somebody's got some memories
back what happened
with a big boner or whatever we woke up
no i hadn't had that so you're like oh
sorry nurse i have the [ __ ] rams logo
on your pants
[Laughter]
i had some situation where like i got
put under for a scope and i woke up
because i had uh like the muscles in my
chest all
relaxed like usually you're tight and
they're or they tightened up either one
i think i came here exactly yeah it's
been a while
uh
and then i also woke up with the scope
still uh down my throat oh [ __ ] no way
man yeah yeah but they didn't give you
enough for i guess not they might yeah
they have to monitor you right yeah they
didn't give me enough when they did my
uh colonoscopy i woke up in the mid and
i didn't have anything down my throat i
had something up my ass
that's pretty good are we going with
taking your kuloi
hey they said hey they send people home
man if you're cool and clean enough man
they're like hey
what's the matter
they they they go in there
and they check it out and they're like
wake his ass up hey you got kudos
i put breath mints up there
fresh
we found seven tic tacs in there
we thought he had kidney stones there
were tic tacs
we like to say no big
but the truth is little things can
really add up and suppressing emotions
only gets you so far okay suppressing
emotions all right
when somebody has something that they
want to tell you and it's in their mind
and they're
and you know you want to say it but you
don't know how it's going to be received
this is what talk space is all about
like if they you know when women say
just tell me what's on your mind
if you do
without a trained professional you will
be
living in the garage letting everybody
in the main house know when the dryer
has turned off so go to talk space
because they're ready to help you with
that you know that's why guys i think
don't aren't as open
because we're not trained
to say
if i'm gonna say this
but i don't know if it's the right thing
to say talk space eliminates that stuff
so now you go in there and you go in
there and you you're like okay
i know i explained to my therapist what
the issue is and then they told me
address it like this which is usually
way off of the way a normal person who
hasn't been a tough space would do it we
all talk to our friends when we're
experiencing issues but they don't
always give the advice we need that's
true man [ __ ] friends they listen
what about when you're living in your
car
drinking water from somebody's water
hose
and your friends see you and they go man
are you living in your car
and you go yeah
oh did you break up with your girl yeah
oh i knew you know what i knew
everything about it like why didn't you
tell me because you look happy okay
you can't rely on a friend to give you
what a therapist is supposed to give you
that's all i almost say talk space
one time hey how about this
when i was working during the day i went
to a restaurant to have a drink after
work in the corner was a guy that i knew
and he was with a girl
no the girl was with another guy
and i knew the guy she was dating and
they were
at las jalas on
balboa
balboa and nordoff
far out of the neighborhood but i live i
worked up the street so when i went in
there and i turned i saw him and they
saw me and they went like that
now i had to say do i tell
jerry
and i told his brother
and his brother said let's tell him
i haven't talked to that dude in
almost 40 years i never talked to him
again after i
wow and i don't think talk space would
have said that's the right way to do
that i saw that guy all the time we were
friends
and since that incident
never spoke to him again
so hey start feeling better with just a
single message i just gave you examples
that everybody deals with every day
match for the license therapist when you
go to talkspace.com and get 100 off your
first month with
the promo code omghi
that's 100 off when you use code omghi
talkspace.com
[Music]
but nobody should
take their health for granted at all
because if you think it's if you and i
mean the body's like you know this is
how
because you're latino they have to you
know [ __ ] doctor talks to you because
you you know how a car when it gets hot
and the oil light goes up [ __ ]
i've been to the doctor before you have
to talk to me
[Laughter]
clipper the big that's the rick clifford
but
what to do doctor he says you realize
you're overweight and i said i just hope
you learned more than that in medical
school
i'm overweight yeah they all tell you
when i was in uh i think i had um thanks
what do they call that stuff with yeah
when you're sighted you're like part of
your
pancreas pancreatitis pancreas yeah yeah
do i take it out from a swollen
you see those commercials we talk about
pancreatitis and all that stuff that
that [ __ ] is
painful
it's [ __ ] awful
and
i was in detroit with those on tour and
then we went to st louis to shoot
something and
as i was walking every time i took a
step it hurt on this side
and i was like every time i took a step
so i jumped up and down because the
mexican the mexican doctor in me and i
jumped up and down and both times it
hurt right there because then you know
your body so i told the dude
the director i said hey man
at
lunch see if you can find a doctor to
come and check me out this doctor comes
in there and he goes hey man you gotta
go to the hospital man i think you got
pancreatitis
and i said uh all right so i was in
there
fluids and whatever medicine but and it
went away and never went back but
there's people that live with that it
would be awful to live with
i've never never had any i got a high
pain threshold but i've never had any
issues have you ever any other
that should you don't want you don't
want to yeah
do you know what like caused it or i
think it's bad bad diet or somebody
could have a bad diet sure or i think
mine was [ __ ] deal hugely drinking
like uh
okay [ __ ] what's wrong with the
[ __ ] banana in the drink of
uh i like old some like liquor with a
banana
daiquiri but is it better no no an
old-fashioned
okay
what's in old-fashioned old-fashioned
bananas
yeah banana might be novel uh
i did sugar and then more sugar yeah
muddling sugar with bitters and water
adding whiskey and then garnishing with
an orange slice
that is the most common way to do it
so a lot of sugar
and it's sugar
and something you can't your body can't
process like i had a spinach salad
and some sugar in there and it's not
you're not processing it and
i only had it there i would not i don't
know if i would i would do if i had to
live with that [ __ ]
100 of the time there's only once i had
i thought my head was going to explode
and
they found out i had
whether your hat was too tight
increased intracranial pressure and they
did a spinal tap
and i could hear it going in the
stainless steel pan
you know the fluid and it was just like
getting a thermometer that was ready to
burst you know red on top and just like
that and you could i could feel it going
down
and i felt like any murphy and trading
places i don't want to say it's a
miracle it's a miracle
because my headache went away it was
just increased inner cranial pressure
with a fluid buildup
and they never did find they never did
find out why because of pentecost at the
hospital
by mistake threw the fluid away
they didn't save it for an ounce of you
know
they had taken me in there on emergency
and then they threw it away
so
now that there's
a thousand things to watch
there's a documentary called dr death
on discovery or history
this guy
in dallas went to he became a
a surgeon neck surgeon brain
spine surge spinal
and
he was arrogant
he worked on his body paralyzed his body
they were doing coke the night before
and this dude
got hired was working with
with credible spinal surge surgeons and
then the guy was assisting him
and he was like saying hey man
i don't
you got to do this it's bleeding he goes
no just put just put a thing in there
and you know suck up because no no no no
no no
you don't you know this guy's bleeding
and that normal blood was like it's like
a hundred milliliters it's like hey man
i'm gonna take over for you right now if
you don't do this and he's like no no i
can paralyze that guy
took the wrong [ __ ] disc out
paralyzed his friend
and that dude
was killing people man [ __ ] yeah when i
went back i talked to uh one of the
doctors who's doing your doctor not that
one doctor death that's not your
i went back to the coroner's office
after i had this thing and they drained
it in the front and the corner the
doctor over the corners office says
you're lucky you're here with us today
and i said what do you mean
he says when you have energy increase
the inner cranial pressure what they're
supposed to do is put a shunt you know
drill a hole in your skull and drain it
from there
because what happens we get at least
three cases a week in here when they do
a spinal tap like that
the spine and the neck where all could
it connect it collapses and pinches and
you die right there when they're doing
it
here's lucky you're still here with a
scene
so
give the number out if you have if you
had an issue with a doctor if a doctor
botched a procedure a lot of times
sean the guy that works with santana
went to mexico to get some new teeth
because it's too expensive here
i said were those teeth buckets still
warm when you [ __ ] put them in so
a lot of people are going to mexico you
see a lot of
uh
plastic surgery a lot of botox stuff a
lot of implants like girls want
a big kulo listen
my aunts had fat asses i didn't think
one of them was [ __ ] attractive
with a fat ass
it's like i don't know when a fat ass
that feels like they're changed
kardashians that real
i don't know i don't know that's real i
don't think i think they were like a big
part of why you know the fat ass came
back around
you know what
i'm going to say that but i probably
won't make it on the thing
like the beverly hillbillies he took a
shot and the oil came up
and all the beverly hillbillies became
rich
the kardashians one sucked the dick and
moved
[Laughter]
imagine not having to suck a dick and
you get rich
i'm the first billionaire that's still a
teenager
what do you do i don't do it my sister
sucked a dick
we all [ __ ] whipped movement moving
on up
to the east side
it was like the beverly head billy's
you got to see the way she she was
driving they had some kind of awards
they showed her on tv today one of the
kardashians
and they showed her that for the matt
gala stuff yeah
she went full full black black you can
you couldn't see your face
looked like a shadow it's hilarious you
know everybody she dated was black so
about time she was going to go
holy [ __ ]
it's one of those [ __ ] suits where
the hotter it gets the dye goes into you
did you see her did you see any pictures
because that is what she looked like
i'll see if i can pull one up
i mean what are we doing man she looks
like that
i i'm not a big star with darth vader
yeah yeah there you go i mean
just had to tell
had to tell black
the truly just looks like a shadow on
the on the carpet
uh
yeah you see that you yeah i saw it on
the news oh it's almost like uh
somebody in afghanistan with money like
one of those ladies they're just like i
think a niqab is like the full full-body
one
one of those ladies had
had money
you know that they don't have money
but that's also you know when we when we
live how about this when we lived here
you two like went to school
they never taught you about the middle
east there was no middle east no they
didn't teach you about
iran iraq afghanistan
sudan whatever whatever
and then all of a sudden so
they live by those things where
the women are also served they cover
themselves and even in uh the taliban in
in afghanistan now where they beat women
like walking down the street man with us
with like a rubber stick or some [ __ ]
that then i mean that's
terrible
it's awful yeah yeah they you can't do
anything they beat the [ __ ] they stone
you cover your knees
yeah
stone you yeah
beat people up still
they were going door to door to try to
find people who
um had even
were dealing with the americans america
and taking them out on the spot
you know
i wish the drone was around when i was
in high school i would have [ __ ] said
some [ __ ] drones
all over pacoima sylmar
we'll just send one to the ram stadium
i use drones to
use drones like a peeping tom
look at stuff you know you know that
that's how that's how stringent the
drone
laws are with the faa yeah that you
don't when they came out
you go outside
you would hear
you don't
nobody has them anymore you don't see
them because i get super strict yeah
and you know what those same laws should
be
applied to any listening device or video
device because you know they used to fly
over neighborhoods they talked about
amazon
how and then you have the helicopters
with law enforcement
that are flying low much lower in
aircraft up on top you know they're in
their airspace yeah they're dangerous
yeah i mean i think that's a big part of
why they banned them right is or they
just instituted that level of rules
because i've always wanted one
but i was you know
just to play with you know but there's
no place you can fly them no no i mean
they really are stricter if you can't
find any of them around you know that
people are at least people you know
there's one thing people agree on
clearly is
you can't [ __ ] with a drone and think
you're going to be
undercover
because you know they would have what a
dodger stadium they would have it during
the games they still use that wire on
football games where you just usually
use a drone
and
you can't you can't you can't [ __ ] with
those things because like this violation
would go in your backyard when i moved
in that house
there was one in the neighborhood and it
was moving around the neighborhood i
said let me keep an eye on this thing
it's over like my house it's over there
and you can hear it and you're like that
can't be that can't be good somebody's
casing out your house and something yeah
feels like such an invasion of privacy
every time
but anyway they're already listening to
what
all of us say anyways sure phones and
all that
podcast
like uh
black gold
xst
you know you know uh kim k was paris
hilton's assistant when her hilton sex
tape came out
so a lot of people think
there was a little bit she saw her blow
up at post-sex tape maybe kim k is like
hey can i build an empire off of one of
these
who's to say but the rest is certainly
history
yeah
right history history
so you're out in vegas uh performing as
well right you weren't just there for
the game i went
uh the taco thing didn't pan out didn't
tell me i would get shot
um we would not want that when i was in
lubbock we got to lubbock we flew
from austin to lubbock and we get to the
hotel has the ten commandments outside
the hotel
that when you walk in on a granite stone
almost like a headstone
the ten commandments so when you go on
the hotel don't be trying to pull no
[ __ ]
in here because we got the ten
commandments at this hotel elegante
and um
i ordered some food to get picked up and
as i was looking at grubhub uh george
lopez tacos were on there no way really
in lumbeck yeah it's you know what i
think it's been
i think i want to thank the people that
everybody but i think it's the biggest
brand for
doordash that they've had like it's
doing is doing really well
you know they go
you can say oh it's just much more than
we expected
you know which means to me and gail
would be like nobody got choroid because
you know they're like hey you know the
expectations were high
and you know that it's delivering a
little below what we expected that means
somebody got choro and put on their yelp
[ __ ] that
they're like if you get shorter man that
spreads faster than choro
people if they like it they like it but
you somebody gets the shits one [ __ ]
kulo just like
kardashian one one whole could blow up
for everybody else
oh the holes give it and the holes take
yep you're only safe in the tank did you
guys get the tacos
no yeah
i did by the way
i did taste for the first time george
lopez
oh
it is the bomb where'd you get it
my daughter remember i was telling you
last week my daughter bought a bunch she
bought everything they had
and so i'm in i'm in dallas and i call
him i said what are you guys doing she's
all we're eating tiffany brought some of
that garden
i said chicken [ __ ] you guys are eating
while i'm not there i wanted to taste it
so i'm home saturday and she come by the
house i said thanks a lot
you know i wanted to taste this stuff
and you didn't bring any she says oh
okay
speak before you learn she had it she
had a left a package for me inside my
inside the refrigerator in my house
so we the wife and i we had some
it was so good
so tasty so tender
uh we're telling everybody about it the
wife is saying okay let's go buy our own
chinga so i'll put it in the freezer
where did she buy where did she buy it
at the food for life for last year food
for less and and she talks to the
to the meat department there and she
says well how's it selling you know is
it is it doing good not so good
she says no
well it everybody and she says have you
tasted he said no
and she said you gotta taste it it's the
bomb it's
she says well the local mexicans around
here don't want to buy because they want
to buy fresh stuff they think that this
is not fresh and i'm here to tell you
it's fred it is good yeah so the old
lady first chance we get we're either
going to go to food for less or cardenas
and get us about 10 packs of it put some
in the freezer and
because it is good okay so when you buy
it it's fresh if you take it home and
put in the freezer that that's on you
but when it ships like the day day or
two it's it's always fresh yeah and you
know mom being a little gordito he keeps
track of the the gardener salad like
most people watch like gold or silver
you know because there's a kind of
there's a you know they would say you
know goals down you know momo just does
that with carne asada
so he's like you know where he goes
the right now there's a god nassau
shortage
and you know the price is high
so people are a little bit they're
debating what to buy because and that's
why yours is taking up because
we
when we put we put the deal together
with the me the meat guys in san diego
levy brothers that
those guys said we want a bigger cut a
better cut of meat
for a lower price point so you got a
better cut
lower price point
so that when you buy it and you taste it
like that where you go man it's
delicious and it's fresh so you know the
mexicans it goes guys
it's not
when you think that meat got there you
just order it the [ __ ] [ __ ] the
carne asada genie [ __ ] delivers it
they think oh
this this one is this one
in the pack
is not fresh and this one that's been
sitting there in the sun in the light
and the the marinade that it's in
is everything and the marinade you can
that's what we say you can you can
adjust it you can you can use a lot of
it or you can take most of it away
and have it more or less and the and the
boil the same thing delicious just like
i can't say enough about it thank you
the the
scottie cameron guys over there the
putter company and carlsbad they're all
latinos in there and uh i sent them uh
for labor day got no salad and he said
everybody's grateful they cooked it up
it was great
i have a queue at my house i'd pick up a
case of it in heartbeat just to take
because i used to have a big about as
long as this table a big a big blanchard
you know yeah oh yeah i had that with
the steamer steamers on the side
just like you'd see a real taceto out
there and i did the wife said you're
crazy what are you gonna do well i'm
tired of paying four or five hundred
dollars to get that a pacquiao down here
i said i can do it myself yeah but you
know what are you gonna do i said when
okay so i'm not there i'm behind the bar
i'm not out with a bunch of people let
him come when we talk and i can be right
there but you know you so so
there's chicken the chicken's good the
meat's good so
like that like a better cut
you could you could buy more like you
could probably buy
for what you would pay
for two pounds you could probably get
three packs of mine which is almost like
more than
a couple pounds at a lower price yeah
and then you try it because everybody
becomes
everybody becomes a creature of a
certain brand
you know everybody when barack obama was
running for president and then they
asked me to go out there try to help him
you know in 2008 and what i found out
there is that
we
and this is everybody by a certain
amount by soap
by
detergent by
whatever uh you throw in the dryer
anything you buy
um
mayonnaise must like we become creatures
of a habit like you like there's a lot
of wheat bread there's a lot of bread
you'll buy the same bread
and then you buy the same
kind of uh by the same beer you buy the
same eggs
and just become years and years of that
and the next thing you know your [ __ ]
chest is tightening on the operating
table
well it's not a commercial i'm just here
to tell the truth
it's great yeah and one thing before we
get off the ramp if roman gabriel's out
there
thomas i was always my favorite player
is one you know you said you know
everybody i never met robin gabriel so
roman gabriel if you're out there that
you see this microphone here
this is uh your spot i would love to
have you on the podcast roman gabriel i
think he lives in chatsworth out there
still around my favorite ram player
maybe my friend a fair football player
and jim plunkett now
and
the old raider yeah he's uh american
indian
yep yeah he's indian and not in
okay
not in
not in the hall of not in the football
hall of fame playing for stanford i
believe
that's right tell me how
jim kelly
buffalo bills
marv levy
lose four
super bowls
and both of them are in the football
hall of fame
tell me how
tom tom flores just got here how long it
took time
[Laughter]
he was younger he had a little thing
number 31 at the moment he was like 31
like tom
you're not getting ice cream covered
yeah jim plunkett is a
gentleman
a supporter of football
a great guy
an amazing dude like
this dude is like
you know he doesn't cuss doesn't you
know he was always a gentleman gentleman
anytime i saw him on tv and
i think that he should be in the hall of
fame sure
because he won too
and got his ass beat up at the patriots
early on
and john madden said to me it's [ __ ]
funny man john madden's a raider [ __ ]
coach
and and we were doing the upfronts in
new york in the early 2000 when my show
was on and they were in the elevator and
i got in with them
and i said oh hey [ __ ] what do you got
what are the odds that you guys said hey
what about plunkett in the nfl and uh
al michaels was like ah you know yeah
okay you know it's okay then and then
john go no you know he won late in his
career which
and then he took he goes he got he got
beat up a lot
early on i said what the [ __ ] does that
make it better what the [ __ ] you mean
he's like he didn't win early what the
[ __ ] who wins early he like worked hard
and improved
that's tom brady listen
tom brady should be
on top of the [ __ ] should put a
a little about a little room up there
for just him because what this
[ __ ] is doing at what how was he
43 47.
this dude you see that i didn't see the
gate i didn't see the game 34 traveling
it's 44 now this dude is changing the
way that
football is looked at
because it's all about protecting him do
you see it aaron
yeah
that's a [ __ ] big sound so [ __ ]
excited
no no listen i don't i don't even really
watch football but i watch you know how
i like to watch documentaries i think
these the stories are compelling like
this dude's 44 years old
he got a good front line he went to you
know when he when he got when he left
the the patriots he was that team but he
felt like he was under
the rule of belichick
that he didn't really win on his own so
he goes to tampa bay [ __ ] horrible
team and his first year they won a super
bowl it's crazy
i mean
and then gronkowski was uh the gronk ron
came back the only one the poor right
though that was imprisoned of double
murder
he was already gone
god bless him but if he hadn't
you know
shot his friend and left his gum by his
body probably still be playing football
winning championships right now what the
[ __ ] shoots a dude and throws the gun
down
right with dna yeah you got with you
guys you guys didn't have me
again with little [ __ ] uh kaka with
tic tacs in his hair from school yeah
and i can't i i can't that would i
wouldn't have got it because i don't
mess with nobody's due to not even my
own
i think when you're hung over the
chicago i don't know what area that
comes from but it's heavier than the
regular
[Laughter]
lots of unpack there i was hungover this
last weekend i i gotta tell you you and
me man i uh i i want to give a shout out
to the guys from uh dallas
i was you didn't even remember their
names go down [ __ ] shotgun
well most of the guys but this was the
chief
eddie garcia chief police for dallas
police department uh george
rocky jesus they show you their badges
because i think they just got you there
they got me there i spoke they got me
drunk the chief was there supporting his
guys you know
at their conference
for the
combined law enforcement association of
texas
uh it was a great conference
they took care of me but they got me
drunker in a [ __ ] mouse on
wednesday
and on thursday to prove that one day
ain't good enough let's do it again on
thursday how did you wake up thursday
hungover
yeah i couldn't wait to get a drink you
know and then
hair on the dog i i had to get that and
when i called though when i talked to
you on friday
i was dying yeah usually i got to get
back vitamins trying to stay but
yeah after two nights of that you might
need something so so what did you speak
about it was a overview of a serial
killer it's all about the but only the
real [ __ ] the crime scene and everything
else is
three or four hours on uh night soccer
stuff can somebody get away with murder
right now
uh yeah anybody can okay anybody can if
you believe in yourself
you think somebody could suck a dick and
not get rich
[Laughter]
not this video hey so so so let's let's
look at
let's look at a crime like you know
let's look at so
if it's in the where let's say if it's
an apartment or a house you usually have
like some ring cameras you can't you
can't
you don't know if there's going to be
any cameras around exactly for one if
you don't go in the park or wherever
right it doesn't appear that those
killers and robbers and bad guys they're
not they don't care yeah they don't care
about cameras anymore
you know and and the guys that i spoke
with uh at this conference
they were saying we just can't imagine
how tough it was for you
back then solving this case because
today
social media plays a big thing these
pendants talk you know they talk back
and forth so social media is out there
they got that we now have dna
we now have you know it's easier to do
listening you know to do wiretaps than
it was back then you know you still have
to write search warrants up but there's
a lot a lot more tools available
location data from phones sure right
yeah right you get yeah everything like
in chris watts over there in frederick
colorado the guy
that that he said that uh he you know
was alone but then his mistress that
girl that he was uh on the side on the
side that made him feel like a man you
know
he said
god rest god rest soul god rest their
souls it was wrong
but
the
man that's hard it's hard to say man but
i just say i'll just say
in a relationship where the woman is
overbearing to the husband
and
everything that they did was on facebook
facebook live and then you add
multi-level marketing which is [ __ ]
ponzi schemes and everybody
allegedly
that gets involved in those things
rarely make money only the people at the
top they got those like
lululemon is amazing then they got like
la la lemon [ __ ] try to knock it off
and they send you [ __ ] and it arrives
torn and [ __ ] ripped and you're
you're responsible for it and then they
have those parties like tupperware
parties like tupperware i think was mid
yeah uh
amway or uh avon avon
and uh all that stuff was mid-level
marketing
and
that that that person that his wife or
women in general
you know treated him
badly on camera he didn't probably
didn't want to be have every moment of
his life uh video that she and even she
said in the in the thing like maybe i
was too hard on him you know because he
drove the other girl was already
checking them out on on social media
they found her computer like they said
when did you guys meet and she said oh
you know around father's day 18 like
june of 18 and she goes just [ __ ]
people
she goes uh [ __ ] stupid ass they go
so when did you guys meet she goes you
know around father's day like when's
father's day i don't know when is it in
march [ __ ] liar who doesn't know what
his father's day if you i didn't have a
dad and i know what [ __ ] father's day
is
so she's like i think we met like was
father's day like in march
lie
and then
everybody knows that's my wife's
birthday in march i don't know what
happened to you yeah yeah and and then
you know you have one that's mean to you
and then one that's you know
[ __ ] getting it
they were they went surfing in the sand
you don't condone but you understand
which is what i what i've said you know
it's not good here
somebody over here is telling you stuff
that you're not hearing here
you're falling for it and then all of a
sudden you know
you know
as you say
but you don't well listen there's guys
out there oh here's another one what's
the number again uh 818 533 1843 if
you're out there escondias they won't
we'll even hide your voice we'll play
we'll pull one of those things on
there's an eminence bar 20 here
and my wife always smokes a [ __ ] inject
me
i started [ __ ] someone that worked at
target
so so we'll hide your voice in case
because
you know the wife will be listening to
it from another room and go wait a
minute you can [ __ ] just walk in play
that thing again
they women know more [ __ ] than
most dudes care about to know
you know
and it goes the same thing for
reverse roles
guy treats his old lady like [ __ ]
and all of a sudden she finds somebody
when she's at work that's talking nice
to her
same thing happens eating each other's
school laws and then
spermicide so you don't get pregnant
you know when i when i was in high
school i took my my girl my girlfriend
to a motel and you know i try to play
big man and i put my last name as
rodriguez and they're like mr rodriguez
i was [ __ ] looking around the lobby
like
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] asking [ __ ] they
they're calling you
the old fake name backfired but yeah if
you have an issue or had an issue or
you know
um
something with your relationship even
your kids
it's it's always tough you know you
can't change the past
but
it will
come up in the future they will never
forget the past
they will never let the past go when i
was you know hey listen and i was
married for 17 years when anne was
working in casting and when i started i
wasn't even nowhere near being famous i
was doing arsenio in the 90s 91
and when we got married in 93 96 i was
born i said hey you know why don't you
stay home and all work at that time i
didn't i never thought i was going to
have it on my own show ever and if i had
my own show
you don't think it's going to [ __ ]
last you don't think you're going to get
a syndicate all of it is all new to me
i'm asked to drive by warner brothers
three payments late in the three car
payments late
to go pay the rent in person and the car
in person because they say hey we need
that payment today or and i would drive
by warner bros and i would think what
does somebody have to do to get in there
right
so
i work my ass off
the minute the minute
i get divorced
from both of them
i wasn't around i was an absent father
i didn't spend enough time at home and
it's like didn't
and of course now everybody's dinner
[ __ ] dementia didn't we say
in 90 [ __ ] 6
91 93
that you would stay home
and that i would work
and then in 2010
in some [ __ ] high-ass office over at
century city
it looks like i was an absentee father
and i wasn't
i was an absentee golfer no
but you know i i was i had i had to work
man it worked what the [ __ ] yeah and it
it came back and it makes you look like
you were but then they're living in a
you know
an affluent neighborhood
i mean it's the dilemma the breadwinner
right like you're
and i think like listen let me tell you
something these [ __ ] i mean
these they were
in a safari in africa posted on
instagram and i was on tour in some
[ __ ] theater
working at night
and doing shows and those [ __ ]
were sleeping in the [ __ ] serengeti
and i'm over at the elegance hotel with
the [ __ ] 10 commandments in front of
the door
i don't know i'm not bad not bad or
anything just say but you know what
sometimes man like
not all guys are bad not all women are
bad no but you can't
what happens when when people have
issues or relationships or whatever is
you start to rewrite the past like you
you forget about
if even you go to therapy you you
make it you make something a bigger
thing
than it is instead of just you know
telling the truth
you can't dwell on the past you got to
work on the future you know you can't
and if you and if you could did you say
that yourself yeah you i'm gonna go to
[ __ ] steven state cause i bet that's
can't dwell on the past you got to work
on the future you know that's it's uh
it's in the middle of the year in the
men's room
and the men's head that's right i wonder
if anybody ever called a girl from the
bathroom and got blown or [ __ ] anybody
from there we're gonna say for a good
time
like you ever called it like hello hey i
saw your lover of steve's steak cups
uh where are you uh-huh
i'm by the old uniroyal factory i'm all
finished right now my baked potato and
i'm taking half the primer
right i don't think they ever i don't
think that [ __ ] ever worked did it like
for a good time call as anybody called
just someone waiting that was before
that you may have but it's true isn't it
everything
i think
i think as time goes by in marriages
that
you have to be friends you know that
you're talking to somebody who's married
for over 50 years
right
i saw i saw a guy and uh lubbock a
friend of uh his his uh son
was i believe in the navy military guy
suffering from a little you know some
injuries
caused
in combat
and
his mom and dad were there great people
together over 50 i didn't remember 55
years that dude went to vietnam he went
to vietnam
and they were high school sweethearts
and they're together and they looked
like with you and like you and pro like
you got when you see somebody
they just even though there are two
people they look like one person like
they were sitting next to each other you
guys saw you guys up there in the la
factory like you just look at them and
it just looks
it looks it looks like it it fits you
know i told my wife when i get back from
dallas i said hey you know what i
actually missed you you know
i i i missed her i took a you know i
believe in the supernatural right i took
a picture of you and pearl and in the
corner
there's the there's a face and i've
zoomed in it's your high school your
third grade girlfriend
you know what could be me if anna revere
is listening right now she doesn't know
hello
i was born in 49 they didn't even keep
[ __ ] numbers back then so probably
about 57 58 what's your social security
number like
he only has five he only has five
numbers
back then there wasn't as many people on
the earth
i still remember the number that i you
when they when i went into the army
before the now that you so screwed them
but i remember when i went in
it was already one eight eight five
three two two zero eight
and then you become a number right
you're not yeah you're a number that's
how you are when i went down to the
abduction center man and i signed up i
was only 17 but i signed up now he
signed up to go to vietnam because well
i signed up i wanted to go to vietnam
because i was stupid i wanted to avenge
my because i had lost about eight
friends over there already and i wanted
to go get even i wanted to avenge your
death the those guys that you lost were
you guys you went to high school with
you were in the neighborhood yeah they
were all high school friends
and so man 17 i signed up
and the induction center used to be
right here on broadway in downtown l.a
and you go and they said okay all
regular armies
who took you one by yourself uh my mom
and dad took me down there
and
my then girlfriend
you know
yeah and so hey but what you so you so
those guys got drafted or they signed up
no they had all the guys that signed up
over here on this side regular army they
had the rest of the guys that were all
draftees they said count off by twos man
and every one two one two one two yeah
and say okay all the ones right here
you're now members of the united states
army all number two is you're now
members of the united states marine
corps bam if you see guys crying on this
side they didn't want to go whoa
that was it i never heard that that's
okay they were drafted they took these
dudes
and they said okay count them off one
two one two one two one one two yeah
and all the ones over here and all the
two's over here you're now in the army
you're now in the marine so you
so the draft board wasn't a specific no
branch of the military it was just like
a like the place you went to show up yes
and they go one two one two
because marines are amazing so army two
but marines they don't leave marines
behind
and they
rush in and they
they're
they're better machines they
yeah
that's what it is you go around the
united states everybody knows lapd
very few people once you get out of here
know about the sheriffs that's right
that's right and we do the same job we
do just army and marine do the same job
marines have always been tough they're
bad they're awesome and they have better
problems than both do you think that
also you don't think that marines
what's do they have semper fi like does
the army have one
i do
because i don't know what it is
i don't know everybody says hoorah tell
you a quick story it's a quick story
but you would think
like be real sat in that chair and he
said and i grew up in l.a
lapd
and he said right there you were right
there that nobody [ __ ] with the
sheriffs yeah like he goes you'd lie to
the lapd you didn't lie to the [ __ ]
sheriffs because they could kick your
ass that's a good thing and i never
heard that remember that day that yeah
so here i am i'm a lieutenant i have a
off-duty officer-involved shooting at
a uh
norms
in lakewood
it's right on lakewood boulevard maybe
the city of belfast right there i don't
know
but would it happen about sure it wasn't
aspires no no no it was this was norms
remember spires yeah i remember that
i had one right there on florence
two guys go in there two meth heads
and one guy and the only people in there
at three in the morning are the drunks
on the way home
get something to eat so
one meth head grabs the waitress puts a
knife to her throat and says give me all
the money or you're dead
and there's a table and at the table
sitting there one of the guys was an
off-duty cop
and at the table to the right were three
marines
that were eating
and so he just looked over the marines
and gave him a nod like hey i got this
and all of a sudden he jumped up he said
drop it boom boom boom bam guy went down
like a sack of [ __ ] he shot him killed
him
his partner went running out the marines
were reading shots were fired
all they said and we got it down the
paper all they said was hoo-rah and they
kept eating
didn't stop hey this is war hoo-rah oh
is that what they say why did they say
that like is it a thing like a yeah like
a cry yeah exactly the other dude took
off their buries didn't chase them no
they didn't chase them they they were
busy eating yeah they could give up
their food
to get through
what about it yeah go ahead and they got
the guy they they ended up cops
my guys ended up catching them catching
up with them and they got him what about
him boogie nights when don cheeto's in
the in the donut shop movies are wearing
all white yeah and he's in there and
he's his wife's gonna have a baby and he
needs he needs money for like they're
trying to do some stereo you know he
needs money
he's got the dreads he's trying to
figure out who he is and he goes in
there and he's going the guy from the
donut shop and he's like can i have a
couple of easy and and he's like really
sweet man he's like what about this one
these cupcakes that you made for the oh
okay a couple of those
and there's a guy sitting there reading
like guns and ammo big redneck dude in
the donut shop
and that guy comes in and he goes all
right [ __ ] put all the [ __ ]
money in the thing and uh and that guy
and don cheadle can see the dude
take the and he's going he's going like
this he's like no no no no no don't
don't do that don't don't do that
and he turns around
and like
the guy fires at the robber the robber
fires at the guy and falling the guy the
robber hits the clerk
and he's just covered in blood and he's
like this like [ __ ] he looks down and
the bag of money's there and he takes
the bag of money and he leaves
at the end of the movie opens the stereo
shop where he's wrapping
like the months you know the month
stereo like that but that's yeah
crazy that's how fast it would happen
right yeah they're doing their best
i laughed i couldn't stop laughing at
the marines
what is what is uh let's say like
somebody
you know i think
l.a used to be bank robber bank robbery
capital right
like what what is a dude thinking like
when when somebody wants to rob a bank
they're they're already criminals
probably lifetime criminals right nobody
nobody's going to rob a bank as their
first crime but back then the money
didn't explode with some ink or it uh
what what protection does the bank have
from robbery just just the guard the one
guard now they have guard now they have
no they're going back there yeah back
then that's all they had it was the
[ __ ] guard right and silent alarms
and
there wasn't much deterrent
so back back in the day if you went in
there
and you gave the note
and they would go like this
if they did this you were hitting the
sideline right they say everybody
usually three people one's in the thing
got the guard take the guard
one gets up says every put your hands up
put the money in the bag they go around
or whatever they go to whatever and if
you don't hit it everybody's got their
hands up now when they
now when they run out the money's not
going to explode it's probably not
numbered or anything right and they're
going to try
a lot of times they got away it was
la was like the bank robbery capital of
the world so many banks so little
protection
since that time they've gone to
exploding money surveillance state
better security plexiglas you know
around the around the employees in there
yeah they they didn't have anything in
it so you have fewer
bank robberies today than you did
yesterday
if somebody's trying how is somebody
gonna rob
a bank now probably online like why like
through
to
tap into something oh sure i mean sure i
i don't even know that's like wire fraud
or stuff like that yeah where somebody
can get can get in there and they can
just like send
money to somewhere else or some [ __ ]
like that
i have no idea i've never been in the
bank business no but i mean what you
know atms even you
you know you atms you you put your
you're getting money
and you can't look behind you at the
same time yeah then they put that little
guy like rearview mirrors put that
little [ __ ] rear view mirror there
where you can see something like a wider
a thing you can see somebody but
people can [ __ ] jack like that too
man yeah go get money and you know go to
a club 11 30 1 30 in the morning go
waiting for you
but now i think it's impossible to
you don't really see a lot of banks
being around yeah what was it was it was
the north hollywood shootout oh that was
a big shootout crazy and that was bad
bank robbery and they were all dressed
they were dressed for war you know it
was a war head-to-toe body armor of
those guys i remember that day so they
went in there and uh there's that one
dude shot himself right he was taking
fire you could see him too so they're
all there was that that north north
hollywood right there the on uh probably
burbank right down burbank here where we
are it was north hollywood shootout yep
the burberry there's a lapd out the
freeway at burbank those probably those
guys
those dudes went in there
they were firing
and [ __ ] they were firing through
[ __ ] cars man they're like yeah they
were using armor-piercing bullets it was
a great uh too bad people so many people
got hurt but the lapd did as good a job
as anybody as they could have under
given circumstances their swat guys did
a beautiful job
in the end catching the second the last
guy
and i think that if you if you see the
video of that guy as he's walking
you can see his his body
like just puffs like getting hit
right so he's you can see him getting
hit they're firing on his ass he had
[ __ ] a full
head to toe armor i'm surprised he
didn't go down even even though it
didn't penetrate right because it's like
getting punched
but and then he i think he shot himself
man i think he shot himself up here
under
uh
did the guy you see him checking the guy
like the two died the only two deaths
were the perpetrators but let me see how
i was out there golfing dude when i went
when all the [ __ ] was going down got
robbed
don't mess up when rick james died i was
golfing right there he died he died at
the oakwood
they got a new documentary out on rick
james
um did you show what a coach you know he
was yeah
oh i gotta watch it then do you hear the
news about north macdonald oh yeah nor
mcdonald passman passed away that's
something that elijah dude there
mcdonald yeah saturday night live 61
young guy
good dude too man dry funny i never knew
he had cancer roll each year nobody knew
yeah no problem
yeah
and then um bruce elford did a show norm
uh and it was successful norm was on abc
it was good
and norm was uh
god bless a man nor they were gamblers
they
in between scenes they'd go out there
and they'd bet on football during the
thing they'd go no come back and go back
out there and then go back out there
man
yeah they were having again we're having
a good time god bless
there's two you know
god bless them
it looks like both of the gunmen were um
were were killed by uh officers and then
when you see the line of fire when you
see what those [ __ ] bullets did to
cars man over two thousand rounds were
fired it says just crazy when did the
assault weapons show up
who had it who had them the military of
course right after
they started showing up after vietnam
you didn't have you didn't have assault
weapons what did you you know
yeah it was an assault weapon
helicopter oh no we had a machine gun on
helicopter but though we had a machine
gun and plus there was a backup by an
ar-15
oh so they were okay they were how long
have been around that that [ __ ]
we got ours they were brand new when i
got there it was 68 but you could never
get one in the you couldn't go to a gun
store and get
back then could you no no you they
weren't available out here they they
started coming out with new ones out
here
and
didn't take them long before they
replicated them and started selling them
oh but you're right um
phillips was shot eleven times including
his self-inflicted gunshot wound
he showed himself under the yeah after
he took the fire he took listen man
i don't know how i know so much about
crying about this stuff yeah don't right
don't i know more [ __ ] about you do for
a dude that [ __ ] gets scared every
time a cop drives by i know a lot of
[ __ ] about crime
[Laughter]
but yeah that stuff like um
the
you know i'm not anti-you know
i don't really like guns but
uh the assault you know in the schools
and all that stuff man it's like it's
just
like those two kids that in columbine
started the whole [ __ ] thing
i mean it's it's it's insanity you know
yeah
when you get to the there's got to be a
root to it why
and and with those kids especially
the root
i didn't study don't everybody hate me
the roots started in their home
you know their parents are responsible
you know they didn't know and and
you know back when i was a kid you get
in trouble in school you get your ass
beat you know and and now
today you get in trouble in school and
it's a school's fault
right you know they're not holding kids
responsible there there's no
ramifications for it
you know jody's not going to get in
trouble that bad okay you're punished no
no xbox for the next week right
so there's no kind of took away his
electronics for a week yeah no
consequences that'll teach him lack of
respect and it's just a whole different
world
um
when i was in high school
uh
february of
i got a dui i was working at the liquor
store i put the beef jerky in my cool
uh
none of it was ever returned either so
ladies it's still a sweet
vodka vintage
so so uh
i got a dui
[ __ ] the ernie that guy was with told
my great i would have got out the next
day but hey i just went uh my
grandfather didn't talk to me for a
month he'd walk by me in the hallway and
to me
that
it was painful
because he was avoiding me didn't want
to talk to me
and and you know now you take a kid's
electronics away they'll give a [ __ ] but
back then when i mean he wasn't he
wasn't my father it wasn't biological
grandfather but the fact that i lived in
that house and the fact that he didn't
talk to me or look at me
for a month it affected me
it affected you know because it's like i
i wouldn't i would have never told him
hey [ __ ] i never told him to go [ __ ]
himself i never
you know i threatened to we threatened
to fight one time he told me he was
going to hit me grab me by the chest
[ __ ]
dude that worked in construction for 30
years i'm like kind
you don't want the smoke
i don't want none of that i do have some
[ __ ] hands like
and i respect even though i was i was
not a bad kid but i was more i was more
afraid of what he was going to do than
what i was going to do if it didn't go
like i wasn't trying to do anything
behind his back but he however he raised
me
with fear or whatever i i have respect
for him
you know i didn't i wasn't running
around doing [ __ ] in school
the other guys i went to school with
they would leave school during the day
and do go do home robberies they'll
[ __ ] rob people's homes and come back
to school and show the [ __ ] that they
got and i didn't i didn't go with them
and then two of those dudes one dude
died and the one of them
has probably been imprisoned for 40
[ __ ] years
no [ __ ] for robbery or something
something murdered oh sure but i was i
wasn't gonna i wasn't you know i didn't
want to i didn't want that kind of life
i don't think i'd all the guys on my
block they either went in the military
or they they might have dead or a person
i think like they told you huh yeah just
like hey
best advice anybody gave me like
muhammad ali in kentucky he could
somebody stole his bike
and
he went to the police station and said
somebody stole my bike i'll kick his ass
i said well you should learn to fight
you know we're going to kick somebody's
ass and down below in the police
department like they used to have a
holland back there boxing
that a guy that was there that was a
fighter police and then ahmed ali goes
in there becomes a fighter becomes
the greatest of all time because he
stole his bike
that's crazy i didn't know that did he
ever recover his bike
never got his bike back then he came
back from the olympics with his with his
uh medal went to a diner in louisville
where he's from
they wouldn't let him sit at the counter
asked him to leave
took his [ __ ] medal went over to the
bridge and threw it in the do it in the
lake is that right
so he said what's this worth nothing
i come back my gold medalist i can't sit
in the restaurant i can't eat in the
restaurant
he said he threw it in
like he did he did yeah that that's why
at the time in 1969 that's why i want to
go back to vietnam i was in georgia and
it was the same way i'm still segregated
yeah that's not the way i was brought up
i didn't want any part of it i'd rather
go back and fight than take my chance
over there than live like this you know
today that on cnn they were talking to
the secretary of state and grilling them
about afghanistan so things go on 20
years and now this dude because of biden
is in the [ __ ] hot seat for [ __ ] that
every one of those uh legislators
senators or house representatives they
knew what the [ __ ] was going on and this
dude is sitting there man and he's gotta
be i'm i'm watching and thinking like
they're beating this dude up for [ __ ]
that they all voted for and [ __ ] that
they all knew that was happening and
then that
some other
senator i remember his name
said
were you interviewed it's like the
dude's like were you interviewed by the
fbi sir and he's like
were you interviewed by the fbi sir and
he's like you know i'll talk i can talk
to you you know away from this about
that he goes were you interviewed by
that he goes and he's saying like hey
man
i'm not supposed to
you're not supposed to ask me that
[Laughter]
i can't say i'm not were you sir are you
avoiding the question it's like
[ __ ] hey it's me yeah the [ __ ]
you doing you're putting me on
i can't
i can't i'm not supposed to say
it's [ __ ] fbi it's [ __ ] ca [ __ ]
where are you it's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
so it looks like he's avoiding the
question but he's not supposed to answer
such national security is it it's a
national security issue
and there you are
i think those [ __ ] hearings should be
held at steven steakhouse
if they have a crab over there or just
think yeah they have crab i'm gonna go
over
anniversary yeah exactly we're going to
go to steven's steakhouse there we go
that's looking to the future are we done
are we good
you can wrap it up you want to wrap it
up let's do it that's our like hour and
a half yeah
leave uh leave some voicemails tell us
your your medical stories other stories
we want to hear at 818 533 1843 okay
here's something
that's going to this is going to happen
tomorrow
so yesterday
get an urgent email
and they asked me if i wanted to be
in the final
as a mentor to uh
gina brion she's a puerto rican uh for
america's americans america's got talent
i was a host during the golden buzzer
time
every everybody watches it
so
one of my favorite shows yeah so so she
says they said to her who who are you
you know who are your mentors said well
george i knew she'd shoot you know never
met her before but i knew it
they call me and they go
they want you to you know be on stage
with her
uh
i said well do i have to do stand-up and
then they they send me a thing of david
spade
and a girl doing going back and forth
but he was almost
like i'm putting her down a little bit i
don't want to do that
so i go to the raider game
last night today i called her at 11
and
she said that they had the idea of like
they play
low rider and she doesn't come out but i
come out and then she comes out
and then you know we do the thing and
they were like they like that and i said
i said well how about she said what do
you what do you think and i said how
about this
how about we walk out
and i say to you i've never seen anybody
who's been more prepared
to perform in the finals than you i
think i think you have it in the back
she goes yeah but you know we come from
like a superstitious you know
culture you're never really sure if
superstitious i said yeah that's true
and i said you know i found a penny i
don't think and she goes you know it's
good luck to like shave your head and i
said uh i remember i never heard that
never heard it's a good luck to shave
her head yeah she goes yeah it's good
luck to shave your head i said well are
you going to shave your head she goes no
no i want to shave your head
this hair right here you want to shave
this hair
[Laughter]
get her a manscape
we're using mascara we need the
lawnmower four points i'm gonna let her
shave my head on america's got no way oh
[ __ ] no way
because i think that it'll go everywhere
it'll be viral
it's like the hair even at the radar
game they're like that [ __ ] hairs
so yeah this it's a good looking man
dude
it's all coming off here a whole baby
should uh you should have her on the pot
afterwards either way
when are you going to tape this one
tomorrow
so it'll air next week then
or maybe it'll look tomorrow's uh i'm
not sure i'm not sure what it is it
might earlier i don't know oh it's live
they do it live oh then they're doing it
live oh oh drink drink it in there
before
do you know what time that is i'll see
if i can look it up
how's this picture good come over here
in this case get behind me take a selfie
beautiful don't let me put it over there
don't be fingering me like last week
so that's what i can say right now
because next week when this is on yeah
so by the time this airs they'll that'll
already be out
very exciting
you guys are seeing the future in the
past right there's a middleware let me
get on the other side that lights the
way
this one i don't know [ __ ] norman
rockwell got to get your good side yeah
that's good the lights
[ __ ] head's huge
maybe it'll make my head small look at
that
fantastic that'd be fun i think it's fun
that'll be great
i'll be excited to see that
live shocking to everybody right i mean
yeah
that's great
when do you start filming your or does
the show start your
the woman mine yeah
uh i think in november look at my eyes
on tick tock doing [ __ ] i'm just like
it's about the it's like man that's when
they're gonna start shooting it yeah
and you know i'll see her do [ __ ] she's
funny man but it's like
shaking her head it's like
it's like that's that why i work so hard
to get one tick tock and shake your ass
but check it out if uh is that why i was
an absentee father so you gonna be out
there shaking your ass
if you haven't seen it by the time
you're watching this episode go check
out that clip because you'll see it
you'll see it awesome i thought it was a
good idea and then she i i talked to her
at 11 and then while i was in here she
um
she
said they love the idea it's like a [ __ ]
how could they not
awesome i don't think the judges are
going to know either so it's going to be
a complete surprise
i just hope
uh they let me at well
even if they keep me overnight
tv and then tv in there
oh you both got big days tomorrow yeah
are you staying overnight no
i don't know
they haven't uh
they said in all likelihood it'll be an
in-and-out procedure
i think that's all like what do they
call the outpatient or one yeah right
and uh
was yours outpatient aaron
yeah
hey man well listen when i had my
colonoscopy
the girl that was the anesthesiologist
was saying oh you know we know a mutual
friend
and when i woke up my [ __ ] hand was
like three times bigger because i guess
i moved in the thing
and it broke the it came out of my hand
so when i woke up they're you know
they're waking me up and then they're
explaining to me hey you know we were
under you know
this i could have moved who knows all i
know is this [ __ ] hand was three
times bigger than this hand
and it all happened while i was on like
under and you're like [ __ ] man like what
the [ __ ]
when they when they did your colonoscopy
did they find any beef sticks
you know
they found
on the sugar walls right there they
found some hickory flavoring
awesome well thanks guys
we're done one more did you get your
check here yes i did thank you very much
cool thank you thank you thank you
meanwhile stitch brother daughter came
here and took a [ __ ] uh got to uh
yeah
she got it
she got uh new uh spade
she was fun in the hall yeah oh what a
cutie one of the cutest cute little
things and then there's one here where
she chewed up the
the uh
the pillow like took the stuffing out of
the pillow and then oh yeah carolina was
like you know
she was hiding
and then
she you know they know they this dog is
hilarious she's like upside down in the
thing like
right there like oh yeah upside down
like like
upside down like
she knows she's [ __ ] up yeah
all that [ __ ] how's your dog
my dog's doing great my dog's on his
back all the wants you to rub
rub his belly rub his pants on
he's got a cute little pen that's
something like an octagon
with uh blankets and his pillow in there
at night all we do is unzip it before
the dodger game's over
unzip it let him hey
go home and he goes inside
zip it back up that's what he's saying
how did you see him again
how did i see him he found us he was a
stray dog
and he just came by his somebody had
really treated him bad he was skinny
ugly skanky couldn't get next to him
uh my neighbor and myself both called
animal control they came down
and then they finally said here's a
leash if you can get them
we'll come pick them up because nobody
can get close to them
and i just told my wife we can't let
this dog be out there you know without
feeding them so
paper bowls
first water and food and he'd come and
he'd eat food yeah drink water and then
he'd go [ __ ] around the neighborhood but
it wasn't my dog so i didn't care
and i wouldn't follow and then he'd come
back
at night and he'd sleep he had a cozy
little man and so he knew he knew
and i finally got to the point where i
just let him come up and he finally
started eating out of my hand
and then he'd roll on his back so i
could rub his belly
and so i finally went took my car for
service and i called the wife up and i
said okay
that squad will be there uh this
afternoon oh my god she says
what do you mean i said well that you
wanted me to call animal control they're
just going to take them and kill them
because she wasn't a big dog lover yeah
and so i came home and when i got home
she had stainless steel bowls stainless
steel food and a bed
and i said oh i guess this means we get
to keep the dog
and i had already run in the internet
local neighborhood
lost dog he wasn't chipped or anything
no no took him down get him checked and
so i don't know who made out better the
dog
or us there you go you know i'll rescue
dog and the thing is
it's funny man because of the pandemic
of course you know it's hard on
everybody but it a lot of people have
abandoned
their pets
and there's a lot of pets that need to
be
uh my wife loves you know that's like
her companion now you know she's pissed
off at me she's got the dog right there
right
yeah so don't buy any dogs everybody
just go out there and rescue a dog
because they're and they're good i mean
they're good anything you find that you
want to buy there's there's they're out
there unfortunately the dog is the one
that suffers obedient i think i've heard
him bark maybe four times since february
it doesn't bark yeah uh i [ __ ] hate
when dogs listen that's what they do
yeah you know that would be like if my
grandmother cooked and i'd every time i
said [ __ ]
that [ __ ] cook every day you say
that's what i do not right now but they
you know every time they bark my [ __ ]
drives me crazy
he just and real quick and the only
first time we heard him was some man was
walking as his doberman pitcher would
have eaten my dog for lunch
but he walked in front of my yard and
like the dog's out front with us
and all of a sudden he felt that that
dog was going to threaten his territory
so he started
and i said [ __ ] get over here dog that
dog will eat you son and i got him back
he barked just a couple of times he
barked when somebody's going to try and
jump my fancy one after him you know i
just get back over here perro
yeah yeah yeah but he's looking out yeah
which is what they do man like they
listen i've rescued enough dogs to know
that
you know there's even a dog psychic like
this this uh ladies these are melons
like hey didn't seem like i had a dog
that
killed
janet jackson queen latifah's dog i
don't know yeah
it's his dog oh
alleged let me say and he had it off
leash and and the
i don't know you know a pit bull off
leash brother
i ain't trying to see a [ __ ] pit bull
off leash holy [ __ ] okay uh pitbull once
owned by canine trader caesar milan
mauled one of queen latifah's pets to
death and the reality st and the reality
tv star tried to cover up the attack by
telling his staff to tell latifah that
her dog was hit by a car
so his dog attacked latifah's dog
and he's told his people like tell her
he was hit by a car that's worse than
telling the truth isn't it that's right
i do believe we learned that from the
vatican the neighborhood elias uh
oh this is oh this is from like this
week
oh i thought this was like a while ago
wow
but i mean damn
does it hurt his brand yeah i think so
it's got to that's what she said
that's like we used to go eat and you
try to put a [ __ ] pedal away like a
pube in there like hey
do we have we don't have pubes and
stephen steak and we're all [ __ ] all
the employees of shade that one you
[ __ ] brought
all right let's go awesome thanks guys
you